[Musique]
Niagara s'illumine pour le temps des
fêtes et si les touristes sont moins
nombreux à admirer les chutes ils
peuvent maintenant le faire à partir de
nouvelles ongles grâce à l'ancienne
centrale électrique de Niagara qui était
fonctionnel de 1905 à 2006 avant de
devenir une attraction touristique
tout avait été laissé intact mais
c'était sale et poussiéreux se souvient
le PDG de Niagara purks qui a supervisé
le processus de restauration
des centaines de milliers touristes ont
visité la centrale dans la dernière
année dont beaucoup d'Américains
intrigués par l'ouverture de nouveaux
tunnels près des chutes
et les leviers captivent les visiteurs
il faut prendre l'ascenseur pour
découvrir le clou du spectacle à une
cinquantaine de mètres sous terre un
épousant tunnel qui rejetait loup dans
la rivière à l'époque où la centrale
était encore fonctionnel
de formation il fait partie des 500
personnes qui ont participé à la
restauration de la centrale
est une fille
et au bout du tunnel de la lumière oui
mais aussi une vue exceptionnelle des
chutes du Niagara
la vue est meilleure d'ici constat deren
au corner un habitué des chutes venu de
Toronto pour voir le tunnel
que les visiteurs se fassent mouiller ou
non le tunnel leur permet de voir une
merveille canadienne sous un nouveau
jour et de découvrir l'histoire méconnue
de l'hydroélectricité en Ontario ici
Radio-Canada Niagara